La conclusion de cette lettre, elle est quelque part si ferme, si grave, que son introduction.
Ce qui fait de cette lettre une lettre unique, même s'il est plus probablement la première lettre de l'apôtre Paul.
Car dans la plupart de ces lettres, on a toujours les mentions à la douce communion, à des éloges qui sont faits, à des salutations.
Mais ces choses sont complètement absentes dans cette lettre écrite au Galate.
C'est intéressant car l'objectif suprême de l'apôtre Paul dans cette lettre, c'est de véritablement protéger la compréhension de l'évangile de la grâce seule.
C'est de protéger la liberté véritable des chrétiens.
C'est de les délivrer d'une relation névrotique avec Dieu où c'est par les menaces ou la terreur qu'ils doivent chercher à maintenir leur relation avec Dieu.
Au départ de leur conversion, Dieu était un père pour eux.
Ils réjouissaient de cette paternité, de ces pardons, de cette grâce.
Mais à un moment donné, les légalistes se sont infiltrés, les judaïsants, et on veut lui suggérer que leur relation avec Dieu devrait être comme cette relation d'avant.
Par leurs efforts, par leurs performances, s'ils ne sont pas à jour avec les exigences religieuses, les exigences de la loi, même la circoncision, ils ne seraient pas bénis par Dieu.
Ils seraient toujours traités comme un douziens rang des chrétiens.
Et donc Paul, il est en train de lutter pour les vrais évangiles, pour leur vraie liberté, pour une relation enfant-père avec Dieu.
Donc nous ne pouvons pas douter que cette lettre découle d'un amour qui n'est pas fin.
Cette lettre découle d'un intérêt réel dans la liberté, dans la paix et dans les vrais saluts, et notamment dans la vraie sanctification des Galates.
Donc on ne peut pas perdre de vue que ces exhortations, cette fermeté, jouent un rôle très important comme évidence d'un amour-rêle,
sans lequel cette église ne laissera pas corriger, sans lequel cette église va succomber à l'influence des imposteurs,
deviendra à nouveau esclave d'une relation distante et religieuse, ritualiste, d'apparence avec Dieu.
Cette conclusion, elle nous rappelle de la vulnérabilité de l'église.
La grande problématique ici, c'est que nous savons très bien que comme l'évangile est un message de grâce,
un message de pardon, un message que nous devons apporter envers tous les peuples,
toutes les personnes, peu importe qu'elles soient leurs péchés.
Et en même temps, nous savons très bien
que de manière externe et apparente,
plusieurs personnes peuvent apprendre à faire semblant qu'ils sont chrétiens
et à utiliser même des mots bibliques qu'ils savent dévoire et pouvoir marcher
quand ils font une expression verbale
ou quand ils dissimulent un type de comportement.
Même Esaïe a pu sembler chercher vraiment la répentance en pleurant
lorsqu'il n'était pas répentie comme la Bible l'a dit.
Donc la vulnérabilité de l'église peut arriver même à ces épisodes
où des imposteurs peuvent s'enfiltrer
et avoir un comportement entre nous
qui arrive même à tromper les mieux d'entre nous.
Et quand on voit les judaïsants qui avaient toute cette apparence,
qui avaient une connaissance théologique suffisamment développée,
qui sont allés au-delà même de ces judaïsmes qui refusaient les Christs
et qui pourraient même réclamer une certaine connexion
avec les apôtres de Jérusalem.
Par contre, leur théologie était biaisée,
leur vie était hypocrite,
ils n'étaient pas des vrais chrétiens
et ils portaient donc un grand danger à cette église.
Les dangers
de détourner les Chrétiens du vrai évangile,
de la vraie piété,
et les dangers d'exploiter ces Chrétiens
pour rendre de la faveur envers eux.
Et les dangers les plus éminents,
notamment,
c'est de les rendre esclaves à nouveau
une fois qu'ils étaient affranchis par l'évangile,
et de provoquer une séparation
et une scission
entre cette église,
qui est une église légitime,
du père spirituel qu'ils ont eu,
par les privilèges d'avoir comme père spirituel
l'apôtre Paul lui-même
qui a implanté cette église.
Et donc, notamment,
la séparation d'épaule
représentait la séparation du vrai évangile.
C'était une église, donc,
sous des grandes menaces,
mais ce texte nous rappelle,
comme l'apôtre Paul est en train de dire ici,
« Ne vous y trompez pas,
on ne se moque pas des dieux. »
Moi, je suis en train de faire beaucoup d'efforts
dans cette lettre
pour clarifier ce qu'est le vrai évangile,
pour clarifier ce qu'il y a les vrais chrétiens,
pour vous exhorter à marcher dans l'esprit.
Et si vous négligez,
si vous choisissez
de succomber plutôt aux influences des imposteurs
qu'il y a de chercher la vraie piété,
plus tôt, plus tard,
la main de Dieu va peser sur vous
et Dieu viendra honorer
ceux qui cherchent à être fidèles
au sein de cette communauté.
C'était une église
où la grâce
était d'un côté abusée
et de l'autre côté
supprimée.
Et des fois,
on se sent vulnérable
à ces choses au sein de l'église.
Certains qui cherchent
à abuser la grâce de Dieu,
car Dieu est si bon,
je peux être si méchant.
Il y a aussi ceux
qui cherchent
à supprimer la grâce de Dieu
pour être eux-mêmes
les repères de la religiosité.
Et donc,
lorsque l'apôtre Paul
arrive au verset 11,
nous sommes devant
ce qui est la consolation
de plusieurs pasteurs,
prédicateurs,
comme moi-même.
Et pourquoi ?
Car la conclusion formelle
était déjà faite.
Toutes les défenses théologiques
et même les exhortations formelles
étaient déjà écrites.
Par contre,
on a l'impression
que Paul ne va jamais finir.
Et pourquoi ?
Car il n'est pas préoccupé
d'avoir un rapport
envers cette église
comme s'il était
en train d'exercer
une profession.
Il n'était pas préoccupé
que son serment
ne dépasse pas
les 35 minutes.
Il n'était pas préoccupé
tout simplement
avec la quantité
de temps
que les personnes
lorsqu'elles sont venues
à l'église
étaient prédisposées
à rendre
et à consacrer
à ces moments.
Il était intéressé
à la destination
éternelle
des âmes
de ses auditeurs.
Il était
avec un cœur pastoral
engagé
avec les choses
qu'il écoutait
à propos
de ses âmes
qu'il tant aimait.
Et,
plus probablement,
comme il va dire
au Corinthien,
il ne dormait pas bien
dès qu'il a écouté
les nouvelles
à propos
du danger
des Galactes.
Donc,
un vrai ministre
des dieux,
un vrai pasteur,
un vrai prédicateur,
il n'est pas
tout simplement
en train de traiter
un moment
de prédication
comme s'il était
tout simplement
en train de démontrer
ses capacités
rhétoriques
ou littéraires
pour restructurer
un très beau serment.
Cette conclusion
à l'être d'épaule,
elle n'est pas
nette.
Elle est remplie
d'affection
et comme les textes
vous l'ont dit,
vous voyez avec
quelle grande lettre
je vous ai écrite
de ma proprement.
Il y a un contraste
lorsqu'il y a
les Galates
qui ont reçu
cette lettre
entre la plupart
des choses
qui ont été écrites
jusqu'ici,
car Paul faisait
usage des ammanuances,
des assistants
avec beaucoup
de qualités
pour rédiger.
Donc,
on peut imaginer
ces hommes
qui étaient
des assistants
personnels
de l'apôtre Paul
et qui ont pu
peut-être
s'exercer
dans ces domaines
même professionnellement.
Le plus probable
c'est que dans
les cas de l'apôtre Paul,
ce soit des personnes
bien entraînées
et soit Paul dictait,
soit Paul révisait
instruisait,
mais à un moment donné,
Paul est en train
de réviser la lettre,
il arrive à ses points,
il prend la lettre,
il écrit lui-même
et il écrit
avec des grandes lettres
remplis d'affection,
remplis des passions,
hors formalité,
quelque part.
Mais ce n'était pas
un discours très net.
Ce n'est pas du tout
l'objectif
qu'on devrait voir
par exemple aujourd'hui
dans plusieurs cercles
évangéliques.
Maîtriser les discours,
maîtriser la littérature.
En même temps,
c'est glorieux aussi
de remarquer
que même cette conclusion
n'est pas absente
d'une structure formelle.
Et je sais que parfois,
quand on rentre
dans des commentaires
un peu techniques
de cette lettre,
on peut être un peu
découragé
de nous plonger.
mais l'une des choses
qui mettent
le plus en évidence
l'inspiration
des Écritures
et la gloire
surnaturelle des dieux
dans la parole des dieux,
c'est la manière glorieuse
dont les dieux
surnaturels
vont gouverner
l'apôtre Paul
sans supprimer
ses capacités.
Car pendant toute sa vie,
l'apôtre Paul
l'a été préparé,
l'a été instruit
de manière très élevée
dans les techniques
grecques,
romaines,
dans les lectures
et dans l'écriture.
Et c'est tout simplement
magistral de voir
d'un côté
que Paul ne va pas
négliger
ses formalités
et ses structures,
ses capacités humaines
si vous voulez,
mais de l'autre côté
c'est incroyable
de voir la liberté
qu'il se donne
d'aller au-delà
de ses capacités,
de sortir
du cadre formel
carré
de manière
pour plus
que tous les commentaristes
et tous ceux
qui ont les contacts
avec les lettres Pauline,
ils savent reconnaître
combien technique
il pourrait être
et en même temps
comment il a pu développer
quelque chose
de très personnel.
Pourquoi ?
Car ses épîtres
ne sont pas
des lettres postales
ni des traités théologiques
tout simplement.
Ses épîtres
sont comme
des sermons
prêchés.
C'est comme
si on était
devant des lettres
qui nous exhortent,
qui nous sécouent.
Et ça montre
vraiment l'une des marques
les plus importantes
d'un ministre authentique.
Quand on pense
à la vulnérabilité
de l'Église,
on voit de l'autre côté
de quelle manière
Dieu préserve
l'Église.
et Dieu préserve
l'Église
par son intervention
directe,
on ne se moque
pas de Dieu,
j'ai du zèle
pour mon Église
plus tôt,
plus tard,
je vais nettoyer
cette communauté.
Mais il est fait aussi
à travers
des ministres fidèles
dont l'apôtre Paul
est répare ici.
Et donc,
quand on regarde
ce qu'on appelle
techniquement
comme les poses scriptum
ou la pré-écrit
ou la souscription
de cette lettre,
on voit un élément
de la littérature latine
très intéressant
qui était tout simplement
l'autographe final.
Les derniers paragraphes
normalement nets,
écrits,
par celui qui était
le responsable
du contenu de la lettre.
OK ?
Et donc,
Paul,
il l'est fait.
Il est en train de dire
je signe des mains
proprement
pour que vous soyez sûrs
que cette lettre
vient des mains.
Et dans quelles conditions
nous retrouvons Paul
lorsqu'il veut
que cette église
soit assurée
que c'est lui-même
qui écrit ?
Ce n'est pas tout simplement
que cette église
aurait pu douter
qu'il s'agissait
de Paul,
mais c'est pour
le rappeler surtout
d'une couche
des relations
personnelles
et pastorales.
C'est moi-même
qui suis en train
d'écrire,
mais aussi
rêve-tu
d'autorité apostolique.
On ne se moque
pas des dieux.
C'est une déclaration
qui doit valoir
avec son poids
suprême
sur tous les chrétiens,
mais on ne se moque
pas des dieux.
Et moi-même,
Paul,
je suis en train
de vous écrire ça
en vous dirigeant
cette exhortation
avec l'autorité apostolique
que Dieu nous a donnée.
Et nous tous,
lorsqu'on est en train
de lire cette lettre,
en faisant confiance
à l'inspiration
de la parole
vivante des dieux,
quand on est en train
de voir un Paul
qui appelle l'attention
à cette dernière section,
c'est comme s'il était
en train de dire
« Ne pensez pas
à une autre personne.
Ne pensez pas
à ceux qui vous entourent. »
Il y a une implication
clairement directe,
exhortative
pour les imposteurs,
mais la lettre
est dirigée
à vous,
les Galates.
Vous allez continuer
d'être naïfs
et connivants
vers ces influences,
vous allez continuer
d'ignorer,
de cultiver
les biens
sans vous fatiguer
ou vous allez continuer
de vous moquer
des dieux
ou d'embrasser
les exhortations
de cette lettre.
Ce qu'il passera
à dire
est complètement
connecté
avec cette exhortation
qu'il vient de faire
et aussi
sera davantage
renforcée
par ce qu'il dira
après.
Mais ce n'est pas
tout simplement
la souscription
pour son authenticité,
pour son autorité.
C'est aussi
très bien structuré,
même si
de manière
très passionnelle
avec beaucoup
d'affection.
Mais c'est
ce qu'on appelle
la conclusion
grecque
classique
qui était
plus exhortative
et qui résumait
l'argument
principal de la lettre.
Et donc,
c'est très intéressant.
Je vous appelle
l'attention
de les faire
avec moi,
de revenir
à Galate
chapitre 1
verset 6.
Et vous allez
remarquer
que dans
tous
les bons
discours
bien structurés,
en serment
bien structuré,
une lettre
en traité
bien structuré,
on doit avoir
une introduction
qui appelle
suffisamment
l'attention
des enjeux
et de l'importance
pour attirer
l'attention
des auditeurs.
Et lorsqu'on va
conclure la lettre,
nous allons
refaire la connexion
avec cette introduction.
Nous n'allons
jamais
comprendre
les niveaux
des duretés
de l'apôtre Paul,
jamais comprendre
les niveaux
d'exhortation,
de sévérité,
surtout dans
une génération
qui est toujours
en train de nous
encourager
à nous victimiser
et qui a
rebaissé tellement
les paramètres
de sainteté
et qui veulent
qu'on considère
les chrétiens
de manière
très légère
et superficielle
comme telle,
jusqu'à
ils ont répété
une prière
ou car ils ont
appris
que si jamais
ils tombent
dans un péché,
il suffit tout
simplement
de confesser
avec leur bouche,
sans déchirer
les cœurs,
sans transformer
leur vie.
Et nous sommes
tellement habitués
avec une idée
des dieux
qui n'est pas intéressée
à notre sainteté
que nous pensons
parfois que l'apôtre Paul
est très dur
dans ces passages.
Sauf que nous n'avons
qu'à ces paramètres,
les paramètres
du Nouveau Testament
pour savoir
ce qu'il y a
en vrai chrétien.
Ce n'est pas
l'Église
d'aujourd'hui
qui va déterminer
ce qu'il y a
l'Évangile
ou ce qu'il y a
en chrétien.
L'idée
des chrétiens
charnels,
on ne les trouve
pas dans les Écritures.
À chaque fois
que les exhortations
se dirigent
vers la carnalité
de ceux
qui se professent
chrétiens,
c'est pour mettre
en question
l'authenticité
de leur foi
et de les exhorter
à démontrer
des fruits
des répentances
et des sanctifications
sinon
ils ne peuvent pas
se convaincre
à être chrétiens.
Et donc,
au début de la lettre,
quels sont les enjeux
de cette lettre ?
Je m'étonne
et c'est 6,
chapitre 1,
que vous,
vous détourniez
si promptement
de celui
qui vous appellez
par la grâce
de Christ
pour passer
à un autre Évangile.
Non pas
qu'il ait
un autre Évangile
mais il y a
des gens
qui vous troublent
et qui veulent
renverser
l'Évangile
de Christ.
Mais quand nous-mêmes
ou même
quand un ange
du ciel
annoncera
ou annoncera
un autre Évangile
que celui
que nous
vous avons prêché
qu'il soit
un athème,
complètement exclu,
qu'il soit
maudit.
Nous
l'avons dit
précédemment
et je le répète
à cette heure,
si quelqu'un
vous annonce
un autre Évangile
que celui
que vous avez reçu,
qu'il soit un athème.
Et maintenant,
est-ce que c'est
la faveur des hommes
que je désire
ou celle des dieux ?
Est-ce que je cherche
à plaire aux hommes ?
Si je plaisais
encore aux hommes,
je ne serais pas
serviteur
de Jésus-Christ.
Qu'est-ce que
Paul veut traiter
en Galate ?
Des imposteurs
qui rentrent
et qui présentent
un Évangile
qui a même
l'apparence
d'être plus sans
que l'Évangile
que Paul a prêché.
Un Évangile
légaliste
qui supprime
la grâce
des dieux.
un Évangile
qui est présenté
par des hommes
qui peuvent même
être comparés
dans leur apparence
à un ange
des lumières.
Des hommes
avec
un sourire,
une apparence nette,
mais qui
détournent
l'Évangile.
Un Évangile
qui va mettre
en question
l'authenticité
du discours
de l'homme
des dieux,
de l'apôtre
Paul lui-même.
Et Paul,
il va définir
non seulement
l'authenticité
de l'Évangile,
mais aussi
l'authenticité
de l'homme
des dieux.
Il ne cherche pas
à plaire les hommes,
mais il cherche
à plaire Dieu seul.
Quand on revient
à cette dernière section,
nous allons
revoir
les mêmes emphases
et les rappels
des mêmes problèmes.
Les enjeux sont
qu'est-ce qui est
l'Évangile,
un vrai chrétien
et comment identifier
un ministre
à qui on puisse
faire confiance.
Et donc,
quand on arrive
dans cette dernière section
que nous allons
plus nous approfondir,
nous allons remarquer
qu'elle est
composée
de manières différentes
de la plupart
des salutations
finales
de l'apôtre Paul.
Ici,
nous ne trouvons pas
de salutations
ni générales
ni envers
des personnes
mentionnées par nom,
comme Paul l'a fait
en plusieurs autres lettres.
Ici,
nous ne trouvons
même pas
de doxologie
en moment d'adoration,
comme si Paul
était dans la joie.
ou comme si
ces peuples-là,
attention,
pourraient joindre
Paul dans une adoration
à Dieu.
Nous ne trouvons pas
d'action des grâces
pour cette Église.
On ne voit aucun projet
de collaboration
ou de visite future,
comme Paul fait
dans d'autres lettres,
même dans des lettres
où les personnes
sont dans des graves erreurs.
La réalité,
c'est que ces lettres
montrent
que la communion
était apparemment
suspendue.
Pourquoi ?
car la gravité
des enjeux,
la gravité
des péchés,
des erreurs
ne peuvent pas
être compensées
à la légère
avec des signes
de répentance
qui ne sont pas
proportionnellement
convaincants.
les Christ
nous disent
qu'on doit
pardonner
70 fois 7.
Et ça,
c'est une réalité.
Tant que la personne
démontre
des clairs
signes
de répentance.
Tant que quelqu'un
soit surpris
dans une faute.
Par contre,
lorsqu'il ne
pas
des imposteurs,
on voit
très souvent
dans la Bible
que les personnes
qui ont mené
un motif
des vies
à long terme
étant récidives
dans des péchés graves
ou lorsque les personnes
sont en train
de négocier
avec les vérités
capitales
de la foi,
régner l'Évangile,
ceux qui veulent
s'émêler
au peuple
de la foi
sans que leur cœur
soit engagé,
nous avons
plein d'exemples
dans la Bible
où
les manifestations
verbales
de la répentance
n'est pas
prise
à la hauteur
des évidences
convaincantes
de répentance.
Et donc,
lorsque Simon
les magiciens
demande
aux apôtres
« Priez pour moi »
quelle est la réponse
des apôtres ?
Que tu pries
toi-même
peut-être
que Dieu
aura compassion.
Un pasteur
n'est jamais
dans la position
qu'aucun catholique
ne devrait être
pour chercher
à communiquer
les pardons
lui-même.
La conviction
du pardon
c'est une réalité
expérimentale.
Lorsqu'une personne
est vraiment répentie
et qu'elle confesse
à Dieu,
l'expérience
directe avec Dieu
lui communique
cette conviction.
David,
il savait très bien
car il n'est pas
devenu
un adultère,
il a commis
mais il n'a pas
démarré
dans cette pratique.
Et à partir
du moment
où il est répenti,
il est très conscient
que les conséquences
de ses péchés,
il va devoir vivre
avec,
avec la soupçon
des personnes
qui l'entourent.
Il sait
qu'il y aura
plein de graves
conséquences
pour son futur,
mais il n'a pas peur
de recevoir
la discipline divine.
Il embrasse
la discipline divine,
mais au-dedans
de son cœur,
il est dit
dans l'Epsom,
c'est toi
qui relèves ma tête.
Quand on contemple
cette période
du traitement
de Paul,
elle est très en phase
avec ces éditions
bibliques
où Dieu dit
je veux qu'il vous déchirez
vos cœurs
et pas vos paroles.
Et nous voyons
que Paul,
pour l'instant,
est en train
de suspendre
sa communion
ou au moins
les plaisirs
de sa communion
avec ce peuple.
Et pourquoi ?
Car l'enseignement
biblique
de l'Ancien Testament,
c'est que là
où l'alliance
est cassée,
où la relation
avec Dieu
est méprisée,
où les comportements
sont un comportement
imposteur,
Israël ne peut pas
goûter
ou profiter
de la lumière
de la face
de Dieu.
Il va comparer
Dieu dans l'Ancien Testament
l'hypocrisie
prolongée
à la trahison
d'adultère,
comme si Israël
avait trahi Dieu.
Et quand on traite
parfois des cas
pastoraux,
c'est très délicat,
car certains,
ils vont s'effier
trop vite
aux paroles
d'une personne.
Et parfois,
même,
les conjoints
qui étaient victimes
d'adultère
développent
une relation
un peu
idolâtre
avec la personne
qui l'a trahi.
bien sûr que
les commandants bibliques,
c'est la prédisposition
à pardonner,
surtout si nous sommes
devant des signes
convaincants
de répentance.
Mais des fois,
on prend des personnes
qui veulent pardonner
très vite,
à la légère.
Et on doit rappeler
ces personnes
qu'ils savent aussi
une attitude idolâtre.
C'est aussi un péché
si lorsqu'elles sont
trahies et blessées,
elles ne reproduisent pas
cette indignation
et cette suspension
des privilèges
de cette relation,
car Dieu fait
comme ça.
tant que la répentance
n'est pas réelle,
tant que les signes
de répentance
ne sont pas convaincants,
Dieu démontre
qu'il y a de l'indignation.
Dieu ne fait qu'il y a
de péser sa mort.
Et les pasteurs doivent
comprendre ces exemples
comme la manière
dont l'apôtre Paul
est en train d'agir ici.
Une église
qui était en train
de mépriser
les investissements
des dieux
à travers un homme fidèle
comme l'apôtre Paul
et qui était en train
de succomber
à l'influence
des imposteurs.
Et donc,
Paul
ne va pas
en serrer
des évidences
des réconciliations
très vite
ou très pressées.
Qu'est-ce qu'il va
en serrer
dans cette conclusion ?
Un autographe
avec grandes lettres.
Voyez avec
quelles grandes lettres
je vous ai écrites
dès ma proprement.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
La première chose
qu'il peut le faire,
c'est d'insister
sur son autorité apostolique
pour redoubler
sur la crainte
du fait
qu'ils ne peuvent pas
se moquer
des dieux
et ils ne peuvent pas
se moquer des dieux
surtout devant un homme
qui Dieu a placé
comme un pot
transpiré.
Il va apporter
des exhortations
au lieu d'action
des grâces.
Il va apporter
cette bénédiction
des paix
que nous trouvons partout
mais dans ces passages
c'est une bénédiction
des paix conditionnelles.
pour tous ceux
qui vivent
sous cette règle
quelle règle ?
On relit
les versets 15
pardon
oui
verset 15
car c'est n'est rien
qu'est d'être
circoncient
en circo-ci
ce qui importe
c'est d'être
une nouvelle création.
C'est ce qu'il dit
aussi au verset 14
pour ce qui me concerne
loin de moi
la pensée
de me glorifier
d'autre chose
que la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
par qui les mondes
est crucifié pour moi
et moi je le suis
pour les mondes.
Donc qui est
le véritable chrétien
à la fin des comptes
ce sont ceux
pour qui les mondes
n'ont plus d'attrait.
Il est crucifié
pour les mondes
car il a déjà
tout gagné.
il est mort
pour les mondes
d'un côté
car leur vie
précédente
était marquée
par l'esclavage
des plaisirs
temporels et mondains
et ces choses
les empêchaient
de s'approcher
véritablement
de la source
de tous les biens
et les biens suprêmes
qu'il y a Dieu.
Paul a compris
en fait
que toutes les choses
auxquelles il était accrochée
comme réputation
avant sa conversion
l'empêchait
de saisir
les biens suprêmes
qui étaient
Christ lui-même.
Mais nous sommes
crucifiés
car lorsqu'on
nous contemplons
Christ crucifié
nous devons
nous voir
comme méritant
être crucifiés.
Donc les mondes
perdent son attrait
pour nous
car on a déjà
reçu
quelque chose
qui est infiniment
plus important
que les mondes.
La vie assurée
à l'éternité
et à la gloire
en réjouissant
la présence
des dieux.
Et des fois
les plaisirs
mondants
marquent plus
la vie
des soi-disant
chrétiens
que la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Et comment
cette réalité
peut être vécue ?
C'est car
cette personne
a traversé
une expérience
des nouvelles créations.
Personne
ne peut conduire
aucun autre
pas à pas
envers la conversion.
La répentance
elle n'est pas
quantitative.
La répentance
qui mène
à la foi
n'est pas
une question
de chercher
à faire une liste
de tous mes péchés
et les confesser
quantitativement.
La vraie répentance
elle est
qualitative.
C'est d'être
répentant.
Ce n'est pas
tout simplement
de considérer
les conséquences
de mes péchés
ou la punition
que j'aurais
méritée
mais c'est
d'avoir
l'abomination
de péché.
C'est une question
des contritions
plutôt que
des remords.
Et ce sont
des expériences
que
personne
à part ceux
qui ont été
régénérés
par le Saint-Esprit
ne peuvent avoir.
Et là
nous pensons aussi
à la vulnérabilité
de l'Église
non seulement
par rapport
aux imposteurs
qui s'enfuitent
entre nous
et qui apprennent
à donner
l'impression extérieure
qu'ils traversent
la vraie répentance
ou la vraie piété
mais ça nous fait
réfléchir aussi
en tant que parents
par exemple
les attentes
que nous pouvons lancer
sur nos enfants
sachant que
nous devons dépendre
complètement
d'une œuvre
surnaturelle
des dieux
pour qu'à un moment
donné
ils se convertissent.
Car nous savons
que même s'ils ne sont pas
des imposteurs
intentionnels
conscients
ils peuvent être
confus
par rapport
aux attentes
des parents
sans trouver
au-dedans
d'eux
les forces
dont nous avons
tous eu besoin
pour progresser
en santé.
La puissance
de cette rencontre
personnelle
avec Dieu
qui a produit
en nous
la vraie répentance.
Et donc
nous ne pouvons pas
enseigner nos enfants
à chercher
à mettre en relation
pas à pas
avec Dieu.
Méthodologique.
et souplier
à Dieu
constamment
souplier
avec eux
à Dieu
et encourager
la transparence.
S'il y a
l'un des péchés
qu'on devrait
attaquer le plus
et chercher
à mortifier le plus
et checker
constamment
chez nos enfants
c'est la dissimulation.
car c'est très
possible
qu'en apprenant
à plaire
les parents
dans un environnement
religieux
ils s'entraînent
constamment
pendant toute leur vie
à devenir
dans le futur
possiblement
des grands hypocrites
au sein de l'église.
C'était la réalité
des hypocrites
religieux
pharisiens.
C'était cette réalité
d'où venaient
les judaïsants.
Ils ont été
élevés
ils ont appris
à grandir
en dissimulant
la piété.
Et ce sont des choses
qui peuvent se passer
parfois
avec des personnes
qui sont sincères
mais qui sont trompées.
l'épouse
d'un homme
des dieux
qui nous appréciera
beaucoup
ils avaient déjà
15 ans
de mariage.
Lorsqu'elle est venue
vers son mari
en disant
tu prêches
dernièrement
constamment
sur l'assurance
de salut.
Et je commence
à douter
de ma foi.
Je n'aime pas
ma belle-mère
comme j'ai des vrais
aimés.
J'ai du mal
à faire certaines choses
basiques
qu'un chrétien
devrait faire.
Elle a pointé aussi
d'autres questions.
en jeu
ils étaient en train
de faire
l'évangélisation
des prostituées
et elle jugeait
trop
ce qu'elle voyait
et elle a ressenti
dans son cœur
comme un réproche
une conviction
qui disait
la seule différence
entre toi
et cette femme
est la taille
de ta joute.
Elle a partagé
ça à son mari
son mari
il a dit
ça je ne peux pas
faire pour toi
je prends soin
des enfants
tu rentres dans ta chambre
tu passes
le temps qu'il faut
c'est à toi
de souplier
à Dieu
pour avoir
cette expérience
qui doit être
présente
chez tous les chrétiens
sans laquelle
personne ne peut
se considérer
un vrai chrétien
et personne n'aura
la capacité
de voir
dans leur propre vie
un progrès réel
en liberté
et en santé
c'est névrotique
de suggérer
aux personnes
qui partent
des habitudes
ou comportements
religieux
même les disciplines
des lectures bibliques
ou des prières
sans la conversion
peuvent être
accablantes
et donc Paul
il va
donner cette condition
il va dire
que tous ceux
qui vivent
sous cette règle
sont la paix
et la paix
et la miséricorde
pourquoi?
car toutes les personnes
qui n'ont pas
la conviction
d'avoir traversé
la vraie répentance
la vraie réconciliation
avec Dieu
par la foi
toutes les personnes
qui n'ont pas eu
une expérience personnelle
intime
réelle
directe
des premières
mens
avec les Christ
toutes les personnes
qui n'ont jamais vu
les fils des dieux
qui ont incarné
et qui ont vécu
une vie parfaite
comme s'il était
en train de les faire
pour moi personnellement
et qu'il était
en train d'être
crucifié à la croix
à cause de mes péchés
tous ceux qui
lorsqu'ils ont vu
l'abomination
du père
envers les fils
à la croix
et qui n'ont jamais
ressenti
cette abomination
que Christ a expérimenté
c'est l'abomination
que j'ai ressent
que Dieu a pour moi
dans ma chair
si cette personne
n'a pas traversé
cette transformation
elle n'a jamais
goûté la vraie paix
c'est toujours
une paix conditionnelle
suspendue
donc qu'ils peuvent
observer chez les autres
mais qu'ils ne réjouissent
jamais devant Dieu
et pourquoi
la miséricorde
car Dieu
il proclame
sa miséricorde
envers tous les perdus
peu importe
qu'elle soit leur péché
sous la condition
qu'ils soient
véritablement répentis
et qu'ils embrassent
Christ par la foi
ce n'est pas
la qualité
de la répentance
ou la quantité
pardon
c'est l'authenticité
de la répentance
c'est les dons
des dieux
comme l'abîme nous dit
et donc cette
miséricorde
elle ne peut qu'être
réjouie
par ceux
qui sont
sincères
sont authentiques
et les empesteurs
chez les Galates
ne peuvent pas
réjouir
de cette miséricorde
pour eux
c'est qu'Paul
est en train de dire
ici
on ne se moque
pas des dieux
la paix
et la miséricorde
ne seront qu'à réserver
pour ceux qui sont
véritables entre vous
et à cet stade
quand vous êtes tous
en train de vous comporter
ou la majorité au moins
comme susceptibles
à vous moquer
des dieux
à mépriser
tous les investissements
qui vous avez reçus
paix
et miséricorde
tant que vous
soyez en train
de démontrer
vivre sous cette règle
ni circoncision
ni en circoncision
je me glorifie
qui est dans la croix
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
et donc
paix et miséricorde
pour les véritables
il y a aussi
un avertissement
explicite
qu'on retrouve
que personne désormais
ne m'efface de la peine
car je porte
sur mon corps
les marques
du Christ
et c'est intéressant
car
il dit
suivrons cette règle
et sur l'Israël
des dieux
très intentionnel aussi
comme on verra plus tard
l'Israël des dieux
c'est pour faire
les contrastes
entre
les circoncines
les ethniques
les nominants
les descendants
des chrétiens
si vous voulez
ou les descendants
des juifs
qui se sentaient
plus importants
à cause du temps
qu'ils avaient
dans la religion
et surtout
leur ethnie
et leur influence
politique
mais les vrais
Israëls des dieux
comme Paul
a bien défendu
dans la lettre
ne sont pas
les descendants
des chrétiens
les vrais
Israëls des dieux
concernent
possiblement
et probablement
les enfants
des chrétiens
à partir du moment
où ils se convertissent
véritablement
où ils sont
en nouvelle création
donc les vrais
Israëls des dieux
ce sont ceux
de la foi
et ensuite
un nouveau verset 18
sa bénédiction
des grâces
conditionnelles
ou explicitement
exclusivement
réservée
qu'est au vrai frère
frère
que la grâce
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
soit avec votre esprit
Amen
l'intimité
du Seigneur
Jésus Christ
avec sa grâce
qui ne sera
qu'est réjouie
par les vrais frères
dans la foi
donc quand on contemple
en considérant
aujourd'hui
rien que cette introduction
à cette dernière section
nous savons
que nous sommes
devant
une conclusion
qui sonne plus
comme un vérédicte
comme un ultimatum
qui est comme
une lettre postale
ou comme un traité
théologique
quel est l'intérêt
des pôles ici
c'est d'être
tout simplement
un médiateur
vous êtes avec moi
entre Dieu
et les hommes
tant que
nous essayons
rien que par nos tâches
ou nos efforts
pastoraux
à mener les personnes
à la foi
ou à la répentance
par nos efforts
on ne va jamais aboutir
on peut perdre du temps
l'énergie
par contre
l'intérêt
de l'apôtre Paul ici
c'est d'être clair
qu'à travers sa vie
et tous ses recours
il plaçait
chaque âme
devant Dieu
voilà pourquoi
cette lettre
va conclure
avec
l'aimente
de tous ses éléments
et l'explicité
de tous ses avertissements
et nous devons
nous laisser porter
par ces exhortations
nous allons
nous plonger
dans la détermination
à embrasser
les blessures
qui guérissent
qu'on puisse
abominer
la tentation
que nous puissions avoir
de nous traiter
à la légère
de fuir
de la sommation
biblique
à nous auto-évaluer
à douter
de notre salut
car c'est
le seul schéma
qui peut nous amener
à une assurance
véritable
dans la foi
les enjeux ici
sont les vrais évangiles
la vraie conversion
les vrais croyants
et les vrais ministres
et verset 12
montre clairement
que cette conclusion
sert à comparer
les vrais chrétiens
des imposteurs
tous ceux qui veulent
se rendre agréables
selon la chair
c'est la question
qu'on doit se poser
est-ce qu'on est
des imposteurs
qui veulent se rendre
agréables
selon la chair
ou est-ce que nous sommes
sous l'influence
des imposteurs
et même si je devrais
embrasser la croix
du Christ
dans ma vie
je suis encore
en train de mitiguer
de mélanger
un amour partagé
entre Christ
et le monde
tous ceux qui veulent
se rendre agréables
selon la chair
est-ce que ma réputation
devant les hommes
est plus importante
que ce que je suis
vraiment devant Dieu
et ensuite Paul
au verset 14
va dire
pour ceux qui me concernent
donc d'un côté
les imposteurs
de l'autre côté
un vrai chrétien
et bien sûr
que
les avertissements
vers les imposteurs
touchent
ceux qui sont
sous son influence
donc les vrais chrétiens
moins grave
pour les chrétiens
mais
suffisamment ferme
vous êtes avec moi
de l'autre côté
l'apôtre
donc personne ne peut
imaginer être
à la hauteur d'un apôtre
mais eux
ils insistaient
qu'ils étaient
des hommes comme nous
et donc l'apôtre
et ceux qui sont
sous l'influence d'apôtre
c'est-à-dire
les paramètres
attention je vais répéter
pour nous
pour apprendre
ce qu'il y a un chrétien
ce sont les archétypes
publics
pas des hommes
parfaits
mais des hommes
qui progressaient
clairement
puis étaient en sainteté
des hommes
qui étaient intègres
dans
la non-duplicité
des cœurs
c'est l'opposé
de l'hypocrisie
la sincérité
la transparence
et donc
nous avons devant nous
deux archétypes
dans ces passages
deux modèles
les modèles
des imposteurs
et je peux me retrouver
quelque part
de ces côtés là
les modèles
des pôles
et je dois me retrouver
plutôt là
ok
et donc l'objectif
de Paul
c'est de conclure
cette lettre
en laissant
des paramètres
finales pour nous
pour pouvoir
nous retrouver
où nous devons
et les contenus
centrales
qui vont déterminer
la différence
entre
les imposteurs
ou les vrais chrétiens
se trouvent
notamment dans les versets
14 et 15
donc Paul
il va dire
loin de moi
la pensée
de me glorifier
autre chose
qui est dans la croix
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
par qui le monde
est crucifié pour moi
comme je suis
pour le monde
et verset 15
car ce n'est rien
que d'être
circoncis
ou en circoncis
c'est qu'il y a
quelque chose
c'est d'être
nouvelle création
dans l'original
nouvelle créature
et donc
nous devons prendre
ces deux versets
14 et 15
et les voir
comme les tests
finales
de l'authenticité
de notre foi
nous devons
nous demander
constamment
si nous trouvons
en nous
des évidences
suffisantes
dans nos vies
pour nous assurer
que les lieux
exclusifs
de notre joie
de notre réjuissance
les sens
de l'être
de l'identité
les suprêmes
et suffisants
plaisirs
la croix
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
et quand on dit
la croix
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
on est en train
de dire
pas tout simplement
dans le Seigneur Jésus
c'est notamment
les scandales
de la croix
pourquoi
car tous les vrais
chrétiens
retrouvent
dans les Christs
à la croix
l'humiliation
que nous devons
tous souffrir
pour mourir
pour nous-mêmes
Christ à la croix
c'est la démonstration
explicite
de ma laideur
de ma méchanceté
de ma misère
spirituelle
c'est les points
de départ
car si nous nous avons
compris par
ce qu'on devrait
souffrir
à la croix
et qui représentaient
bien sûr
l'enfer
à partir de là
en recevant
cette absolution
car il a souffert
à ma place
c'est impossible
de comprendre
l'évangile
sans être
et sans tomber
passionné
de la croix
du Christ
comme les lieux
où nous retrouvons
notre plus grand bien
car c'est indissociable
de penser
à la croix
du Christ
sans penser
à notre misère
et d'où nous avons
été délivrés
mais plus que ça
les seigneurs
Jésus Christ
qui dans le fait
qu'il soit seigneur
retrouve déjà
ou devrait retrouver
chez nous
la plus élevée
admiration
c'est les seigneurs
des seigneurs
c'est les fils
des dieux
par contre
dans sa condescendance
il a été exalté
dans son humiliation
il a prouvé
davantage
son amour
pour moi
un amour
que je ne peux trouver
nulle part ailleurs
aucune chose
dans ce monde
ne peut m'offrir
quelque chose
de plus beau
de plus glorieux
qui est de voir
Dieu lui-même
se faisant chair
et en allant
à la croix
pour payer
pour mes péchés
mais pas que ça
pour m'associer
tellement à lui
en amour
afin que je sois
ressuscité
ou que je sois
avec lui
pour vivre
une nouveauté
de vie
l'être
le plus beau
à la croix
démontre
que sa personne
est infiniment
adorable
totalement
aimable
à travers
cette oeuvre
d'humiliation
qu'il a se fait
à notre place
donc c'est notre
humiliation suprême
et c'est notre
élévation suprême
voilà pourquoi
les vrais chrétiens
il ne peut se glorifier
à aucune autre chose
qu'à la croix
du Christ
tant que les imposteurs
veulent vivre
un évangile sans croix
ils veulent diminuer
les implications
de la croix
pour mon humiliation
et les difficultés
qui vont caractériser
la vie de tous ceux
qui vont proclamer
cette vérité
car tous les êtres humains
remplis d'égo
d'idolâtrie
des soirs
ils ne veulent pas
écouter ces messages
de leur humiliation
de leur condamnation
qu'ils ont besoin
d'un autre
pour faire une performance
religieuse
ils veulent eux-mêmes
mériter
même parfois
rien que les choix
pour Christ
ils veulent avoir
les mérites et ça
et lorsque les chrétiens
voient Christ crucifié
ils se voient
un Christ crucifié
et il est donc crucifié
pour les mondes
pour lui
et il sait
dans son expérience
personnelle
que cette connaissance
salvatrice du Christ
a opéré
une transformation
indoubitable
indéniable
et évidente
dans sa vie
il n'est pas préoccupé
avec les réputations
religieuses
des certains
les dégrés
doctorat
des certains
les curriculants
combien de livres
il a écrit
il veut savoir
si cette personne
dans l'ensemble
de sa vie
se rassemble
à Jésus Christ
s'il progresse
en sainteté
s'il est symétrique
s'il progresse
en piété
on ne connait plus
personne
selon la chair
peu importe
si elle a les fils
du plus grand théologien
peu importe
son ethnie
la réalité
c'est est-ce que
cette personne
a traversé
l'expérience
d'évenir
une nouvelle création
une nouvelle créature
et ça
c'est impossible
de cacher
et ça
c'est impossible
de voir
personne
les personnes
peuvent peut-être
ne pas se rappeler
du jour de la conversion
si ils se sont convertis
très tôt
quand ils étaient petits
mais personne
ne peut
ne pas
voir
les évidences
réelles
des conversions
dans les présents
de leur vie
c'est impossible
d'être habitation
de la troisième
personne
de la trinité
des saints
esprits
sans en être conscient
!
des nouvelles créatures
leurs habitudes
même si bien cachées
se rassemblent
beaucoup
aux mêmes choses
qui cherchent
le monde
car même à l'église
ils peuvent être là
à la recherche
des opportunités
pour leur promiscuité
pour leur désir
charnel
pour leur profit
en termes
des positions
des visibilités
économiques
pour la tentation
du pouvoir
de l'autorité
pour maîtriser
les autres
manipuler
et tout cela
est en train
de diriger
tous les non-chrétiens
dans le monde
la grande question
c'est
est-ce qu'ils montrent
des évidences claires
qui sont des nouvelles
créatures
est-ce qu'ils montrent
des manières claires
qui ne sont pas accrochées
à leur confort
mais qui sont là
en train de porter
leur fardeau
et les fardeaux
des autres
c'est sacrifié
pour promouvoir
la vie des autres
est-ce que
lorsqu'ils tombent
dans un péché
ils sont plus
préoccupés
à être découverts
aux conséquences
de leur péché
à la perte
de leur réputation
ou est-ce qu'ils sont
en train de pleurer
car ils ont attristé
les cœurs du père
et bien sûr
que même si
pour les imposteurs
c'est un message
avec presque
aucune note d'espoir
et même là
on voit de la grâce
car les imposteurs
doivent chercher
la répentance
de cette manière
avec ces niveaux
d'humiliation
de conscience
de leur méchanceté
et c'est clair
que cette exhortation
aura beaucoup plus
d'efficacité
dans les vrais
enfants des dieux
une résolution
aidée par les
Saint-Esprit
à laisser
la négligence
et cultiver
les évidences
claires
car pour plus
qu'on soit tenté
par les mondes
l'effet
qu'on soit
à la nouvelle créature
nous donnera
la puissance
pour surmonter
ces choses
à prendre
des décisions
qui nous font
refuser
les privilèges
et les conformes
pour faire
pouvoir
la piété
ce qu'on fera
d'ici
vers l'avant
dans les prochains
dimanches
c'est de revenir
sur chaque partie
de ces textes
aujourd'hui
c'était plutôt
une introduction
panoramique
pour traiter
cette vérité
centrale
les tests
ultimes
de la réalité
d'être
une nouvelle création
est une vie
qui se glorifie
exclusivement
dans la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
et nous allons
considérer
des éléments
dans ces passages
qui nous montrent
les preuves
de cette réalité
quelles sont
les preuves
d'une vie
qui se glorifie
exclusivement
en Jésus Christ
en opposition
à l'hypocrisie
religieuse
à partir
du dimanche prochain
nous allons voir
l'importance
de plusieurs éléments
dont les premiers
c'est notamment
la présence
d'un amour
authentique
qui se révèle
par des affections
évidentes
c'est cet amour
de l'apôtre Paul
qui est révélé
par son engagement
affectif
avec ce peuple
et nous allons
donc faire
des comparatifs
entre
les vraies
affections religieuses
d'un côté
et les fausses
affections religieuses
car les imposteurs
peuvent être
très dramatiques
ils peuvent même
faire des cours
des rhétoriques
certains prédicateurs
sont même encouragés
à faire des cours
des théâtres
et même nous
parfois
nous pouvons être
trompés
par rapport
à la direction
de nos affections
nous pouvons pleurer
parfois
dans la vie chrétienne
sauf que nos attentes
elles ne sont pas liées
à ce qu'on devrait
attendre
de la vie chrétienne
la croix
l'endurance
la difficulté
mais parfois
on est en train
en suivant
les promesses
vides des imposteurs
on pleure
car on n'a pas
encore gagné
dans cette vie
des choses
que Dieu
ne nous a jamais promis
donc ça sera
par la grâce
de Dieu
très important
pour nous
de nous laisser
exhorter
dans la considération
de ces textes
pour les prochains dimanches
et les autres
des autres